the Joe Rogan experience well really be
[ __ ] up as bugs were big and
intelligent if bugs behaved the way
settlers behaved when they encountered
the Native Americans I I must say I'm
happy to hear you say that something I
say to my kids and I've said to myself
for many many many years is what I'm
having a rough morning I say thank God
praying mantis aren't five feet [ __ ]
yeah dude because getting to your car
would be a nightmare yeah and and you'd
never it'd just be like you know that
yeah I was just watching a video of a
praying man it's [ __ ] up a mouse
they're so powerful man's crazy this is
just to like start the morning it was
just that a normal way to start the
morning is neat yeah oh yeah there was
one with a squirrel - he was the praying
mantis was eating a squirrel it's like
holding on to this little squirrels head
and just slowly pulling it apart oh
there's another one with a lizard the
lizard one was pretty [ __ ] look at
this mouse you think well there's no way
look that melon it's just like oh well
just going over here just gonna look
over here bro they're so ruthless these
goddamn things and they're so [ __ ]
Stu septa vlog for their size you look
at how big they are I mean look at that
dude if that was five feet tall we'd be
[ __ ]
III wouldn't I honestly I would stay
home and a lot more I would be armed to
the dick I just [ __ ] everywhere I go
multiple guns Kevlar suits here he goes
[ __ ] and the way they get some is so
[ __ ] fast well it is a kind of a cool
thing that we don't have to like die
watching something you need us it's
crazy though that there's no it's not a
contest
it's like that in the ear though that's
my idea what our first what I'd like to
move is that that's not that's uncalled
for it's rude yeah you just need iam ear
first if I'm hit by something that's
gonna eat me I'm like don't start the
[ __ ] here man they don't you will
[ __ ] well it really that is what you
gotta hear the mouse did you make it any
louder
you get in deep enough please
get this over with [ __ ] and then you
just feel the sound at that point but
yeah like boulders underwater looks like
pink
it's just crazy when you look at how big
the mouse is and how small the insect is
like for mass of body weight that it's
not even a contest that the praying
mantis just gets it a hundred percent
like it's not like maybe the mouse can
get away like no it's over bit it's a
bit like that orca eats the great white
sliver thing right right where for for
for like a thousand nautical miles in
every direction every single tagged
white shark as soon as that happens the
radius is like a thousand nautical miles
every great white shark was like so
anyways this time I'm out of here and
then takes off really yeah so they felt
it like they knew yeah something about
the smell of their own data of that
really or whatever that you know what is
it the OP you live a little orange any
that that's sixth sense they have oh
right some something about that
frequency for them is sort of like call
you back and they just bail well that's
like the bully getting bullied right
like they're the meanest [ __ ]
in the ocean except for the orcas right
I think at this point in my life I'm
like they don't have hands so they're
like sorry I gotta try it what's going
on here
no hands gonna use this sorry because
when you when you have no predators most
of your time like that what's up Jamie
yet did we mention this before they only
go after the liver oh yeah creepy
well they do for some miracle some
father what fava beans with it so that's
cool probably very nutritious but they
are you kidding orcas are the babies do
that with your mouth I think orcas are
probably the biggest tick of all because
they're just like should go [ __ ] with
that guy and grab liver or what do you
want to do well they [ __ ] up dolphins -
we know dolphins are kind of cute
what more big dolphins well the the
permanent smile right that's I don't say
cute they're just thinking hey cuz it
could be like [ __ ] you well even dolphin
have dolphins commit infanticide they
kill babies they do it on porpoise
yeah well they killed their own two
kinds babies to try to force the female
into estrus
and so as a consequence email all rights
to get them back yet
because female dolphins when they breed
apparently once they have a baby they
they have to raise that baby for like
six years so they won't have sex for
like six years
so what male dolphins do is they will
kill the baby so the force - female to
breed again so what females do is they
become hoes so they [ __ ] everybody and
anybody they can so that if a dolphin
runs into her they go maybe that's my
kid
alright says yeah so they're not sure if
it's their kid they don't even obviously
there's no 23 possible ability yeah
so they know that they [ __ ] her like
the seven great oceans in me or
something well they're really
intelligent right I mean they have a
sorrel cortex is 40% larger than human
beings what when when there was that one
shot and maybe it's black fish or
something like that uh where they put a
mirror up and the Dolphins are like
going in looking at them they're so
aware the like the minute uh that was an
amazing moment to watch like a dolphin
go oh yeah like with a shower with a
hairbrush singing in the mirror sort of
well I can it's like the way we looked
at other cultures we we think we're
better but when we look at orcas and
dolphins just because they can't affect
their environment the way we can like
they can't build houses and you know and
create things yeah we assume they're not
as intelligible create things that we we
would determine to have any value right
right physical objects that's it but but
the way they have culture and
communication and yeah that to have the
sonar and all that stuff they're they're
operating with tools that were like what
yeah we don't even understand what you
highly oh you mean Bing I got that over
here Bing it's like they're using sonar
finding objects in the water and also a
fish
[Applause]